بينما تدخل اوكرانيا مرحله محوريه في
حربها مع روسيا تتطلع الولايات المتحده
الى كيفيه تحويل البلاد الى حصن ضد روسيا
وذلك عبر انشاء نظام امني مماثل لاسرائيل
وفق ما كشفته هنا صحيفه وصف الامريكيه
الاتفاق الامني سيعطي الاولويه لنقل
الاسلحه والتكنولوجيا المتطوره الى
اوكرانيا وسيرتبط هذا الاتفاق الامني ايضا
بعمليه انضمام في المستقبل طبعا ولكن من
دون ان يقحم الناتو في صراع مباشر مع
موسكو وهنا اكدت الصحيفه على لسان الرئيس
البولندي ان نقاش مستمر حول هذا الموضوع
بموافقه القاده الغربيون بمن فيهم الرئيس
الامريكي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات